poor Sean our cooks really confused here
because basically what has happened is
that he has discovered the subscribe
button for the new world review the
pricing of which will grant him regular
hunt onto content uploaded straight into
his YouTube feed sadly he looks like he
will be unlikely to figure that out
however you good viewer well I know that
you have what it takes to be truly great
hello and welcome to the new order video
source for everything anime and manga
and today we are here with the ever
important task of ranking the Phantom
troupe why are we doing this no no how
are we doing this good question as we
all know ranking characters objectively
is a super difficult task especially in
the bottom on tanta so what I have done
is put up a poll in the community
section of New York View asking you all
to vote for your favorite member and
also as a new addition to this poll
format multiple votes were allowed so
for example if you could not bring
yourself to choose between diet for
Phaeton and the gorgeous alluring
enticing franklin then i got you because
hey if you really wanted to then you
could have given every member of our
although statistically speaking that
would mean the equivalent of no votes
whatsoever so with that in mind for this
poll we received just under 15,000 votes
cast just under 22 votes away from such
a glorious round number but i'm really
excited about this actually because this
should give us quite a fine impression
on how the fan base feels about alf
bunky troop members before we get into
the results so there are two exceptions
to this poll that you should probably
all know about before we dive into it
though firstly we are not taking into
account a certain member who joined
during succession war i don't know i
just didn't think it would be fair but i
suppose at the same time who soca was
included so whatever feel free to call
me a hypocrite and secondly the
non-canon troupe member goth dude face
was also not included because he is not
canon and most people haven't seen
phantom rouge anyway but with that out
of the way let's begin and in 14th place
we have core toby who secured a mighty
94 votes which out of close to 15,000 is
it's not great sorry little guy then
again I'm not really sure how much more
we should have expected core toby was
always a quiet background player in the
troop although I personally do really
love his an inability gallery fake which
allows him to make temporary copies of
objects although even then crow lo
borrowed and went on to use disability
much more effective than core Toby
probably of a good so it is hard to give
him points just for that so what does
that leave us with
well he's physically confirmed to be the
weakest member of the
he is more than likely not one of the
founding members and he has never had
one true moment of importance within the
story but in the official dada book his
name is spelt as called toffee although
everyone's name gets butchered in that
book so we probably cannot hold that
against him so instead we're just going
to move on to 13th place where we find
one Franklin Bordeaux having managed to
attain 178 Boat things and I do think
it's quite impressive that he got almost
twice as many votes at school Toby given
that Franklin inhabits a very similar
role in Hunter hunter a more silent
background member of the troupe and I
mean even right now during the events of
the succession wall whilst every other
troupe member is out there getting crap
done Franklin is just quietly sitting on
his own in a cafeteria eating any
delicious dinner and you know what
actually I respect that I'm all on board
with the mindset of just kicking back
enjoying life and then waiting for
trouble to come to you and when it does
you just promptly remove the tips of
your fingers and blast up wooden bullets
simple philosophy and because we brought
up core Toby's name let's also mention
that in the official hunt hunt data book
Franklin is written as funky and
actually on various pieces of
merchandise his name is Helen Killeen
but moving on into 12th place we have
our famous boxing mummy bunola Knopf
with a modest 204 vote clicks and while
he does form another pillar of the quiet
segments of the troupe members but Nolan
off has the key advantage of having had
some time to shine during the Chimera
and talk in which he demonstrated the
ability to conjure the planet Jupiter
and crush his enemies and obviously this
is not legit Jupiter but a mini Jupiter
look-alike and that is still quite
honestly one of the more devastating
indications of conjuration that we have
ever seen in the series although very
notably in order to conjure anything
this mummy first needs to bust a move
and perform a dance but really even
though we've only seen him in action
ever so briefly this man deserves a hell
of a lot of respect for how he wields
nanny and as for the data book in their
infinite wisdom they have decided that
his name is now born on earth which
actually I think is the closest to maybe
accurate that we've encountered so far
so sure good job on that in 11th place
now securing a mere two more votes in
battle on earth is colossal dick and the
thing I find most intriguing regarding
Carlito is the decision to join the
Phantom troupe in the first place not
going to go into all of the options here
because they have another video and the
works for that but his situation is
simply
needing as well as the whole discussion
surrounding white-collar Tony knows how
to use nen whilst Kilwa his older
brother did not as are his demonstrated
in abilities which as with all black
heads all dicks is based in the area of
manipulation and collar tone uses the
medium of paper which can be seen here
in these adorable phantom troops super
happy friendship cutouts but from here
on out we will cease referring to him as
Carlito because the data book spells his
name as cullet zaalouk so what can we do
Hunter hunter really bringing into
question the legitimacy of data books in
general here and breaking into the top
10 now we first learned in the life of
Park uno de who has taken a massive step
up acquiring 454 votes more than twice
as many as Kalitta Zell dick in 11th
place but even if we don't take a beach
attire into account I can really see why
Park uno de would present a tear of her
own pocono de actually forms a
surprising heart and soul of the oak new
city arc and she is one of the core
reasons why the Phantom troop are able
to be humanized into such a stunning set
of antagonists through her quite frankly
noble sacrifice under crop cos judgement
chain conditions so I have a soft spot
for popcorn Oda but I also love her
because she is an often overlooked
specialist which are always some of the
most intriguing abilities that this
series has to offer does the data book
in this situation it would appear that
they had an intern mashed their head
against keyboard and what came out was
Phalke north dick taking another leap up
in votes now shall knock manipulates his
way into ninth place with 626 tics of
profound approval from all of you and to
my experience [ __ ] tends to be a love
him or hate him kind of character as all
blonde ball cuts will be for the rest of
human history and I think that he
initially doesn't come off as a figure
who has really earned his place in the
troop because his ability seems kind of
like a budget illa me but when you
really delve into it you realized that
Shaun Hawk has catered his nen use very
very carefully and to extract maximum
potential which is on full display when
he goes so far as to manipulate himself
in autopilot mode thus becoming the
first and probably only character in
hunter hunter to officially turn into a
Super Saiyan and there's just so much
more to this guy than we got to see if
him in series which might be quite
criminal of Takashi but not as criminal
as the dart books spelling of Shaun arc
which is yon or cool series business
time now and getting into number 8 we
have over gain a man who brute forced
his way into just under 700 votes and
this is my first real surprise of the
ranking because of agin is one of my
personal favorite members of the troupe
but I think that's because he is one of
the most well explored with his own
tragic but kind of vicious character arc
during york new city and you know
initially he seemed like a huge meathead
and your standard anime strongman but he
went on to display a great degree of
intelligence and loyalty that really
makes him stand out and I will never
forget the moment where he told crop
occur to just go to hell
even knowing that that very action would
directly lead to his death he was a very
strong character and certainly not just
in the physical sense although in that
ladder a god he does still remain quite
possibly the most powerful pure enhancer
we've met in the series and he really
did show just how extraordinarily
dangerous that affinity can be and as
for the Dynabook name well this is what
we've got to work with live again is now
Roberto Green yeah moving on to 7th
place now and we have the queen of
sucking she's a GU who gobbled up 739
votes in that there poll which you know
I don't think is too unexpected she's a
GU was always bound to generate fans for
reasons and a couple of those reasons
can be seen on display in this picture
but in general she's quite a charming
individual and someone who does not
necessarily blend in with what you would
initially think the Phantom troupe is
for all intents and purposes she's
Akutan is a highly aloof beacon of
neutrality who has somehow gotten
involved in the great underworld of
thievery and mass murder and I would
love to know the story of how she
stepped into this realm at this point
all we seem to know is that she may have
been from me to your city although not
an original member of the troupe in fact
she replaced the member who was killed
by silver zoldak whoever that was
and here the data book makes the least
sense thus far which she's whose name
being spelt as Chyzyk moving on up to
number 6 now we find Fink's he thinks
magog to be precise who casually walks
into this ranking with 836 votes pretty
good for a guy who mostly makes his way
to real life in a tracksuit what he does
have going in his favor though is the
serious tough-guy appeal the more I see
of thinks the more I enjoy his presence
in the series and I'm quite excited to
see how he progresses in the succession
war on I also really enjoy his extremely
simple but stupidly powerful Honsou
called the ripest cyclotron whereby his
punches increase in power in direct
correlation to the number of times he
rotates his arm and it makes me wanda
want the limit to this is if indeed
there is a limit at all good thinks for
example maybe after roughly a couple of
hundred thousand or even millions of
wines potentially even one
marijuana for example but the best thing
about Fink's is that his donna book name
is mostly right to least phonetically
anyway spelling it as Fink's top five
time now and we begin with Nobunaga
bit of a surprise appearance here for me
I mean I do like the guy but he still
remains one of the lesser explored
members of the troupe although I suppose
what we do know is that he tends to look
quite cool quite cool indeed yes even
when cross-eyed and he has the whole
sword factor going on because characters
who use swords automatically earn an
amped-up degree of coolness that is just
the lure of anime now rather
unfortunately for whatever reason I
could not find Nobunaga's name according
to the data book but I think we've seen
enough examples now to make an accurate
guess as to what they may have dubbed
him and I'm going to assume that his
name in the data book is Nura ball
noggin as for 4th place we find
ourselves with machi who is the first
character in this ranking to gather more
than 1000 votes from this fantastic fan
base 1169 to be precise and precision is
important when it comes to machi because
that is what she's all about just like
with the Nobunaga's sword effect string
users in anime also come with their own
degree of automatic respect and
reverence but I have to say the thing I
love most about machi is that she simply
doesn't give enough although to be fair
that has quite rapidly changed in the
manga events and right now machi is
quite honestly one of the most
intriguing members of the troupe to be
following and if you do want to find her
then all you have to do is look up her
quote-unquote official name which is
Marti call martine yet so according to
this her first name actually goes on to
form part of her second name which is
kind of like calling me liam mccallum
son to third place now we have Phaeton
and the gap between he and Marchi could
better be described as a sort of gaping
chasm with fate and more than doubling
her vote total sitting in the mid 2000s
I don't know who could possibly be
shocked by this particular result though
because fate Han just has everything
going for him he's a dark brooding lad
with a fantastic design a great sense of
sickening humor and even a sword to boot
in addition to this he also has a heart
suit that allows him to conjure a
miniature son so you know take that
banal of I mean what were you thinking
making Jupiter when you could have made
a son such a child's play and according
to the data book his name is spelt as
hatin which makes him sound
significantly less cool not as horrible
as our number-two contender though
because just wait for this one because
in second place we have the leader of
the troupe himself Rolo Lucifer managing
to horde
a 3,000 votes all to himself very greedy
indeed and I think that this one is
pretty obvious no he does not have a
solid or strings but that wouldn't stop
him from stealing one as an ability or
acquiring any other ability for that
matter because krolow is a reservoir of
nen intrigue and watching him in combat
comprises some of my favorite
experiences in all of montanta plus he
does have a proper boss design one that
really makes you stand up and pay
attention
kind of like his name in the dada book
which is cool rough rule suffer because
that's a name but to finish things off i
present to all of you in first place
Hisoka and i'm sure that some of you
will take issue with me including him on
this list but i just couldn't bring
myself not to for a huge chunk of the
series he was associated with the troupe
and look what would have happened if I
didn't I suspect that we would have had
the exact same ranking except everybody
moves up one place but Hisoka is an
obvious fan favorite of noches hunter
hunter but the whole world of anime and
manga in general and it's always going
to be hard to deny him a victory in any
popularity based setting almost as hard
as it was for the data book writers to
deny his obvious name which they got
kind of close but in the end they landed
on his coop me good I think you just you
guys got so close this time around and
yet so never so far but yeah that is
your phantom troop ranking ladies and
gentlemen thank you to everyone who
casts one of the near 15,000 votes and
next up I have a poll asking who your
favorite members of the zoldak family
are and once again you will be allowed
multiple votes for this one post is
currently up in the community section of
the new world view and I very much look
forward to seeing the results but what
do you guys think please do leave your
thoughts in the comments below or even
join my discord server and if you're
keen for small hunt onto content then
please do go and check out some of my
other videos or even subscribe to the
channel for regular hunt on to glory to
live it straight until YouTube be but
for now this has been the new world view
and I'll see you next time